so David what do you do at Khan Academy
I'm a software engineer and what I work
on particular is front-end and so I work
on the features the UI what is you wise
Daniel
oh you is user interface ok so that's
the the buttons the the web page the
things that you see what is front-end me
our front end in front of means the the
side that faces the user so that would
be the web pages the code that gets run
by the browser so if you go to your
comic a morgue and the the things that
you see on the website that that is the
front end so what else is there that
seems like what that seems like Khan
Academy right yeah so that does seem
like what you see but that's almost the
tip of the iceberg beneath that there's
a whole bunch of other algorithms that
that power Khan Academy such as our
recommendation system the backhand which
is what the website talks to you to get
your data and a whole bunch of
infrastructure that supports everything
that you use on Khan Academy
my focus is just on the the user facing
side of Khan Academy although I have
touched other parts of the code base
before and what kind of stuff do you
work on Oh
currently yeah okay so one of the things
I've been working on recently that
you've done in the recent past either
well sure okay one of the things I've
been working on recently is trying to
make the website look a little better on
your mobile devices so if you use your
phone and you go to Khan Academy org
making the content so that it fits the
screen so you don't have to horizontally
squirrel zoom out zoom in etc mobile web
no more what yeah it's also called
responsive web design not an app but a
website on a phone that's right yes what
else
one of the things I'm currently recently
working on is trying to revamp our
donation efforts figuring out what can
we do to more sustainably
yet donations throughout the year some
things I've worked on before was the
avatars making and a customized here for
avatars I'm sure a lot of people be
grateful for that
and what's your day-to-day like like how
does that happen how does an avatar
customizer like how does it come into
reality yeah so it's it's really not one
person's job that like makes this happen
but really a across team effort and so
like the way that something like this
might have happened is one of our
project managers Jason in particular had
the I was trying to figure out what can
we do to make the website more fun more
engaging get users to want to come back
and do more problems and one of the
things that came out of that discussion
was maybe we can like a user seems to
like avatars like a reward system maybe
we could revamp that and put a little
more effort to that make that more fun
so from that from that idea we sketched
out some mock-ups brainstorm like there
are what features we could build scoped
it out and who's we who are you working
with oh right so that that would be so
this is back this is last year this
would have been with Jason who's our
product park manager and a designer with
another developer and kamalo
and another another designer at Tabitha
so this was the core set of folks who
worked on this project in particular and
as the main developer on it I would be
trying to coordinate the efforts but to
answer question about what a day to day
would be like that would be composed of
you know maybe spending like a few hours
on coding spending some time on
coordinating communicating so in the
form of meetings writing reviewing
documents looking at code it's looking
at the code that other team members have
written
and reviewing that commenting on it why
do we do that why do we have code
reviews yeah so what is a code review
what is yeah what is it yeah that's a
question so when we so Khan Academy the
website runs on hundreds of thousands of
lines of code and not and this code
isn't written by a single person it's
written by an entire team of now like 30
to 40 developers and how can you have
everyone working on this code like
simultaneously the way we get that done
is through collaboration software and
collaboration techniques and one of
these processes these techniques is a
comb review and the way that works is
you might write 100 lines of code to
let's say add abundant somewhere and
then but before you make that code life
before you put that on to the website it
goes through what's called code review
which means that you upload the code
somewhere and then other team members
well look at that code and they won't
they will look at just the code that
you've written the changes you've made
to the code and they will comment and
the purpose of this is to just to make
sure that we have a good clean code base
that can evolve sustainably what does
that mean I mean if the code works isn't
that enough yeah this is great I mean
yeah that's a good question like the
thing when you're writing maybe if
you've written programs on Khan Academy
before you might have written like 20
lines of code and it works and you know
but when you restart get making bigger
and bigger code bases where you have
hundreds of thousands of lines of code
it gets there's what's called technical
debt which means that when you start
when we just do the minimum effort to
make something work it makes it harder
for other features to build on top of
that so in as the code grows the more
hacks the more patches the more like
shortcuts you take the harder it becomes
for the code to evolve and code review
is a process designed to try to smooth
that out to try to say like oh like
maybe the code can be written in this
way so that it's more
understand about two future developers
or it's more extensible easier to change
someone else might have to read that
Obrecht likely will read that code is
that all of your code is like variables
like X 5 4 3 2 1 yeah those are gonna
know what that means and that's a very
good tangible concrete example yes when
you're writing code for yourself it
might be very clear what this 20 lines
of code does but then when you start
writing hundreds of thousands of lines
of code you're going to be forgetting
what this widget code you wrote did
before and you're gonna and also I mean
when you have lots of developers you're
gonna be actually spending more time
reading code than you are writing code a
lot of times so it's very important to
write code in a clear understandable way
for future developers for the to be Oh
to consistently maintain a good pace of
writing code so so we want a structure
code in a way that is not only good for
future developers but also in a way that
is sustainable yeah and there as you
mentioned technical debt it might be
that the code might without you knowing
it impact other parts of the system in
weird ways yeah I just want to make sure
that you don't do that and dealt with
with the review process so what what did
you do before Khan Academy Oh before I
started working full-time at Khan
Academy so I was a student at Canada at
the University of Waterloo
I studied software engineering and I
interned as part of my program and some
internships are 34 month work term so
it's three to four month terms where a
student will work at a company and get
paid for them for it so as part of my
program we did six internships so each
of those internships was is a four-month
work work term at a company and the for
my first two work terms were at Google
second two at Khan Academy and then the
the the last two was at a start-up in
San Francisco called surf science and
what made you you know you're highly
sought-after individual what made you
come to Khan Academy yeah so
the first the first time I heard about
Khan Academy was through a combination
of seeing your TED talk
Sal's TED talk hearing about Khan
Academy just just I remember just like
where we were when we were in class
actually trying to study for our
differential equations midterm are the
notes we were given weren't very
complete and a lot of our class used
Khan Academy to study for that and also
on a on the sauce I call hacker news
where are the developer posted a job ad
so like it's a combination of different
sources that I've heard of Khan Academy
but I've always been pretty driven and
passionate about education it's
something I've had a lot of thoughts
about and it's something that I see can
really make a big impact in the world
especially in and I see a sort of a
lever to help to help people help
themselves especially if we can get more
people to you know if you can get like
three times as many people working on
difficult problems if you can leverage
the full potential of all the people in
the world like that that's an amazing
amount of that's an amazing multiplier
on the impact that collectively we can
make so I've always been interested by
education and when I heard about Khan
Academy and what they're trying to do
watching the TED talk I was like this
this is I need to I need to be involved
in this this is this is perfect this is
this is exactly what I want to do so I
entered a Khan Academy I really enjoyed
my first internship worked on a lot of
quite a few different parts of the the
the entire system and I also just enjoy
I really love the people here it's a
small tight-knit family and after my
internship experiences I remembered just
the the overall feeling of working on
Khan Academy just felt that I'd really
enjoy my time here I enjoy the people
and
of course also love the mission so and
since coming I mean what's the
experience like what surprised you
yeah so since returning Khan Academy has
grown a little bit more than when I
started as an intern
what changed I guess what surprised me
was probably the the degree of structure
and it felt like we were a more like a
more legitimate company like we actually
had people who to take care of certain
parts of the company and it's not like
just ad hoc oh well just you know half
extend of meeting right now in here and
we had we actually have like
well-defined processes for a lot of
things that were currently doing and
that we were sort of ad hoc doing before
yeah in terms of surprises what
surprises let me think about that
what are you excited about what am i
okay
I guess I'm excited about like all the
things that we're trying to do oh and
maybe one of the things that excites me
the most it's actually not related to
the software itself but rather something
that we're experimenting with we just
it's called the Khan lab school it's
that it's it is it's this private school
that we have adjacent to our office and
it's basically a private school of 30
kids mixed grade class from grade 2 to
like middle school and higher and we
have kids working on mastery based on
mastery based curriculum so you only
move on till you actually master a
subject and it's come it's it's project
oriented so it's not like you're you
know working through like worksheets but
like we're getting kids to like build
stuff and I feel like I'm describing
what so is like wait what you are like
this is this is your your brainchild but
like this this is the thing that like
that gets me really excited
it's bits I remember reading your book
about you know would you would you see
as the problems of that stem from the
Russian motto of Education and would you
feel what you think an ideal education
can be like and I feel like The Lab
School embodies so much of that and like
this this is something I'm really
excited about because this is what I
wished my education could have been like
well regardless you've turned out just
fine well thank you so much and I mean
it's a it's an honor that you you you
you know to work with you honor to where
to